look what we have here can't see it can
you you know why because I like bloated
and post
let's now you guys know as well as I
know I have kind of an addiction a bit
of a problem and uh I told myself I
kicked it but I didn't choose so I know
that you guys when you guys watched my
videos I talked about people who buy
shoes and when they buy shoes they don't
wear them that's not the case for me
when I buy my shoes I absolutely do wear
them most of the kicks that I had before
that were worth anything I'm talking
about Yeezy boosts and whatever whatnot
I sold all of those because they were
too expensive to put on my ugly-ass feet
so I said you know what you gone now
recently as you guys know I was working
on a film called [ __ ] and after that
film was done or during the film I was
very stressed out of when I'm stressed
out I tend to want to buy things that I
wanted in my childhood such as really
nice shoes and so I couldn't kick the
habit and so I got some new shoes and
just to put in perspective today I got a
nice little gift all the way from London
itself I got made a pair of olive green
and MDS ah now it's been a while since
I've bought a pair of shoes the last
pair of shoe I bought was some air
Presto's and the only reason why I
bought those was because I lost my
flying is all black Roshi's which I
can't even find anymore don't know where
the [ __ ] it is somebody if you got it
you little cinnamon but these are the
shoes to be of the moment now I'm a
little bit over Nike yes I said it I'm a
little bit over Nike is that blasphemous
to say I don't care when these first
came out I wasn't too keen on him
specifically because they got these
little weird little Lego box blocks on
the side wasn't wasn't wasn't it wasn't
digging it wasn't doing it for me
Adina's enemies are by far one of the
most colorful shoes I have ever
hands down next to the ultra boost now
the reason why enemies might be a little
bit more comfortable for some of you
guys out there that have wide feet is
because yes it has a wider base and even
though this is I say roughly a medium
fit shoe for some reason it fits a bit
better for us a ninja turtle feet were
you can streetfighter feet mother look
at this is so light so the croissant
imagine before these apparently were
only a UK release which I don't know why
they actually did this to me before with
the olive green ultra boost which I
really really want but they're being
sold for like an arm and a leg and an
[ __ ] and I didn't just get one shoe
tokyo black and indies there's not a
single thing this shoe doesn't go with
do you understand me so if you were to
ever get these nmds and you're worried
about oh my god these are kind of
expensive i don't know what i could wear
these with well you can't go wrong with
black my friend once you go black you
probably want to stay there
[Music]